a couple weeks ago I made a video called
19 things you missed in truth or dare
and at the end of that video I
challenged you my subscribers to give me
some truths or dares in the comments for
me to do in a video the time has come to
make that video welcome back everyone my
name is cz and this could get ugly real
fast
ok so here are the rules I had you guys
leave comments on my video I told you
that I wouldn't do anything illegal
anything that spends a bunch of my own
money and I wouldn't delete my content I
promise to do the top rated ones in a
video and I'll be doing the top 5 rated
truths and the top 5 rated dares so
let's see what you guys came up with I
dare you to dress like a cat for a whole
things you missed ok next episode will
be things you missed in sunny family
cult on Saturday so how were the cat
ears for that episode I'll think I'll
wear them in this video too I mean I
think they look pretty good on me if I
must say so myself
ok this one has both a truth and a dare
truth what is a guilty pleasure show
slash movie that you like that not many
people enjoyed I would say the happening
I think it was a really cool idea and a
very suspenseful movie it's almost like
the birds but with trees instead of
birds I mean plus what other movie can
make trees seem scary I mean come on I'm
guessing a lot of people didn't like it
because you have to comedy actors and
Mark Wahlberg and Zooey Deschanel and
much more serious roles so maybe it's
not what people were expecting and I
like movies where there's horror going
on but at its core it's more of a
relatable story about human relationship
ok and this guy's dare I dare you to put
on as many shirts and pens as possible
within a timeframe of two and a half
minutes you have to put them on one over
another and they can be anything like a
tank top or a jacket ok well what this
is the weirdest dare I've ever heard
what why is it so specific I mean why
this reminds me of a Weezer video that
I've seen but ok I'm gonna do it and
then I'll just speed up the footage and
show it to you there we go
[Music]
seven pants ten shirts try and beat that
you know what anyone anyone who can beat
that and film it and put it on video
send it to me and if you beat it I will
put it on my channel that's how
confident I am all right so the next one
is a truth and it's asking me how did
YouTube change my life well it's changed
my life twice really when YouTube first
came out I was not a creator and more of
a consumer and it was just amazing to
see the shift from traditional media to
new media you had these videos coming up
a video would go viral and everyone
would be talking about it and it was
just really exciting because there was
nothing like that at the time we had
these creators for the first time you
there was Smosh & lisanova Kassem G Dax
flame and the content that they were
making was just so much different than
anything that you would find on
television or in the movies so it was
really cool to to see that and it just
changed the way that I looked at media
and then obviously it's changed my life
again more recently with me becoming a
creator it's allowed me to make the
videos that I want to make and have my
own career off of it which is amazing
and before YouTube there was just
nothing like that if it wasn't for
YouTube and just online media in general
I would probably be scraping through
footage for some studio somewhere
painting out wires and doing tedious
visual effects oh and then one other
thing I forgot to say another thing
that's like really changed my life with
YouTube is tutorials tutorials are
amazing you can learn how to do anything
you don't have to go and take a class if
you want to learn something even if
you're just doing something around the
house like how to build furniture you
can just pull up a tutorial and see
exactly how to do it you can learn
things that would have taken years to
learn before and you can just do it
immediately
alright next day I dare you to play
outlast 2 for 5 hours or
straights alright here we go outlast 2
I'm taking off these clothes first
though so here I am playing outlast 2
because you guys told me to I've never
played an outlast game before
and thanks to orange Studios for helping
me set this up and lending me his
capture card yeah blah blah blah I'm
gonna get the monetize for this video
Lin Langerman is an investigative
journalist seeking the answer is behind
the pregnant woman murdered under
impossible circumstances in rural
Arizona you are Blake Langerman her
husband assistant and cameraman record
Oh sweetie I get to record stuff neither
of you are fighters to navigate the
horrors waiting for you in the desert
your only choices are to run hide or die
okay so I had a little recording issue
that basically none of that footage is
gonna be usable but I am about three
hours into the game right now so I
figured I'd just play it so yeah
basically this guy he's in the
helicopter with his wife the helicopter
crashes the wife is lost he finds her
eventually after looking around and all
there's all these weird guys called
heretics and you're trying to avoid them
and it's this whole spooky ordeal and
eventually you find the wife but then
the heretics find you and the wife and
this weird lady licks your face and they
take the wife basically so right now
what I'm trying to do is I just started
this generator and I'm supposed to go
back and find this elevator so one of
the creepiest parts in the game happened
just a second ago actually because you
turn on the generator and then like
someone hears you see these people are
weird dude yeah um so yeah you're in the
generator room and this this lady just
like appears behind you and starts
slashing I don't really know how to get
via this lady without getting slashed
right now do I run for it I didn't know
how to run uh-huh
for the beginning of the game either
alright I made it see the camera gives
you this magical night vision which
would totally work in a real camera and
that's not sarcastic at all that lets
you see better than your actual human
eye
oh man oh this is when I see someone
running around like that it makes me
nervous all right just got to get a
little bit further she can get to that
elevator yeah
so when you see one of those people
usually not a good thing yeah and when
you hear a strange noise like that it
usually means I should get the heck out
of here and I can't and I am gonna die
unless I can heal myself really fast
with the band-aid oh wow I just got
stabbed through the stomach Wow
all right that was intense
rest in peace may I give it one more
shot all right she's not paying
attention I'm gonna book it I feel like
if I feel like that things coming after
me all right I'm gonna chill out in here
wait for the danger to subside and I
know when the danger is subsided because
the music right all right I hear
breathing should I check outside the
barrel
I'm gonna check outside the barrel holy
crap he's right there okay I'm glad I
recorded for this part because that is
pretty creepy can I listen in with my
magic camera I feel like he's right
outside the barrel right now oh yeah he
okay he's just went by all right go go
go
I'm sorry I think here's the thing just
got a pull and here I go there's a well
I wonder if there's a temple at the
bottom of the well a little bungo bungo
why did he just say Jessica what what I
guess I guess bungo bungo millions at
the bottom of the wall you know that
there's gonna be some kind of rake
looking thing that comes out of the vent
oh that's that's my girl
all right I gotta go find her oh my
camera battery's gonna die right now
okay wow this is like the least rustic
looking place in the entire game
alright see at this point I'm taking the
scissors first defense but as you saw at
the beginning my guy's not a fighter
apparently that means he cannot defend
himself in any way whatsoever I want to
play a game know what's what's the deal
with this TV
yeah something just ate her out of the
ceiling trying to jump on that desk and
figure out what's going on but I can't
man that guy looks friendly oh my god
I'm actually fighting back a little bit
this is so nice is he come after me oh
crap
I got a I got a book I got a book some
messed up stuff going on all right well
I think that gives you a pretty good
idea of this game so I'm gonna stop it
there I would like to go ahead and
finish this game so maybe I'll post my
updates on outlast 2 on Twitter or
something all right so the next one is
what is your favorite horror game well
honestly majora's mask but I know
there's gonna be people in the comments
who say oh no that's that's not a horror
game and to those people I say
[Music]
but as far as a more traditional horror
game I've really been enjoying duck
season it's a VR game on the oculus I
talked it a little bit about it in the
last dead stream I think but it's super
fun it's a it's a horror twist on the
NES classic game cons which if that's
not enough to sell you already the game
super unsettling I don't want to get
into spoilers or anything so I will stop
there but I will say there are a bunch
of different possible outcomes and just
a lot of secrets to uncover in it
I really really enjoyed that one from
stress level zero alright on to the next
dare I dare you to play welcome to the
game 2 on your channel either videos or
live I would love to see this okay what
is it with you guys in horror games
recently that's three truths slash dares
in a row involving horror games which is
funny because I've barely talked about
games on this channel let me go see if I
can download that okay I do want to play
that but I don't know if that's gonna be
physically possible right now because I
do not have room for it on my PC and one
of the rules was that I don't spend a
bunch of money and I would have to go
out and get a hard drive which would
cost a bunch of money so I think I'm
gonna have to skip on that one for now
maybe I'll do a video on it in the
future but I'll just take another dare
on to the end of this video
truth what is a movie that you're most
looking forward to okay glass I know
I've already plugged a night Shyamalan
once in this video but glass is the
sequel to split which came out a couple
of years ago and I absolutely love that
movie I've been waiting for a franchise
like this for like 20 years almost now I
mean for me seeing split was one of the
best movie going
that I've ever had just the energy in
the theater during the last two minutes
of that movie was amazing and it's got
me super pumped up for glass which comes
out next year dare I dare you to cut
your goatee shoots I should have made a
rule for this that should have been the
fourth rule you can't tell me to cut my
goatee but I didn't do it so I guess I
got to follow through with it I mean it
is getting pretty long right now I guess
it could use a trim it does say cut it
doesn't say I shave off entirely so
that's good but yeah this this is going
to be painful for me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one day it will return so there weren't
that many truths in the comments with a
lot of likes clearly you guys came here
for the dares but here it is truth would
you ever have kids no if there were
babies crying everywhere and stuff it
would make it really hard to record
these videos for you guys also this has
nothing to do with this video but the
comment below that says Slenderman can
kill truth or deer which I just find so
funny for some reason I think I'm gonna
print that out and post it on my wall
okay so I have one more dare because I
couldn't quite do it welcome to the game
one and the next one says dare I dare
you to eat a whole lot onion oh I don't
have any onions right now so I'm gonna
have to go out and grab one that's gonna
be that's gonna be tough
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever eaten a raw onion before
yeah thanks not pleasant not pleasant at
all not just one bite and I can already
feel it this is the smallest one too and
there's no way I'm gonna make this is it
safe to eat a whole onion raw they say
it's actually to stay healthy all right
cat ears the actual taste of it it's not
that bad which is the burning sensation
okay it tastes pretty bad mmm the water
helps I don't think you said anything
about not being wound up water and quiet
big bite this time this is not fun
do not do this do not try this at home
I'm not even halfway there
it burns it just tastes like the
spiciest thing ever right now the first
bite did not can do this uh my tongue is
burning right now I've been rolling the
steak for ten minutes I think I just
need to take a break and come back and
finish the onion okay i sat down for 10
minutes took a little break did some
editing I feel a lot better now I think
I'm ready to get back into it I think I
can finish off like half of this with
the next bite and then hopefully after
that I can just down it and and be done
instant regret it's gonna take at least
two more bites just imagine you're
eating a burger and there's onion on it
a big juicy quarter pounder with bacon
then the burning is right back.that
taking the big bite bad idea because now
then it sits in your mouth and it's
burning how has YouTube changed your
life yeah it made me eat a freaking raw
onion for no reason I would gladly play
ten more hours of outlast too if I
didn't have to finish this onion just a
couple more bites starting to get kind
of a headache I think it's just because
from the stress not so much from the
onion I made the mistake of taking a big
bite again and then I was like no
actually the smaller bites might be the
way to go then you can just down them
with water it's almost like taking a
pill yeah I think cueing it like
releases the juices that make it burn
all right I'm gonna do this chunk and
then I just have this left I couldn't do
that chunk couldn't do it I don't know
how close I have to get to this thing
but I'm not gonna eat the bottom thing
I'm not gonna have onion and on anything
for a long time after this okay I'm
really close just have this bit left
uh-uh it's the smallest portion that
I've had so far I mean it's like the
smallest had been obviously I'm not even
making sense it's really small now but
it looks bigger than it was at the
beginning you know my nose is like
running to alright last piece of this
one too no couldn't do it okay this is
how much I have left I can do this I can
finish this onion last a little bit oh
man oh man that was going down and it
did not continue to go down that was
going down and it came back up and then
there's so little amount left I'm gonna
chew this and whatever happens happens
okay that last little bit just would not
go to hound whoa I still feel sick
do not try this this cannot be healthy I
don't know what that article was talking
about oh okay
alright I got a pack of gum and eat all
of it and then I'm gonna brush my teeth
for about ten hours that's it five
truths five dares leave the worst there
you've ever had to do down in the
comments and remember to subscribe to
seize these world for new Horrors every
week usually it's not gross out stuff
like this I will see you
in the next one assuming we both survive